في رساله مهمه وفيديو مؤثر كشفت
الاعلاميه راندا كراتشا عن اصعب تجربه في
حياتها
قالت لي متابعيها انها حرمت من ان تكون
اما بعد استئصال رحمها مبينه انها اكتشف
ذلك في الرابع عشر من شهر ديسمبر لفتت الى
ان صعوبه الانجاب دفعتها الى فكره تجميد
البويضات لكنها عند اللجوء الى الطبيبه
لهذا الغرض اكتشفت ان لديها ورمين مق
دمه ريحتها بفحص الرحم والمبايض بشكل خاص
لانها طريقه الوحيده لمعرفه الاصابه
بالاورام
[موسيقى]
14/12/2022 اول يوم اللي عرفت هي بحياتي
ما رح اصير ام
اسمي راندا كراتشي وعمري 37 سنه حبيت
اعايد كل الامهات بقول لكم كل عام وانتم
بالف الف خير
عمري 36
بلشت افكر زي ما كنا بنفكر
وحلمنا دائما نصير امهات وهذا اشي بينخلق
فينا بالفطره
وما كنت عارفه اني راح ادخل على عياده
الدكتوره عشان اعمل تجميد بويضات
انا راح اطلع رح تنقلب حياتي
اتفقنا الكسر المبكر عن سرطان الثدي له
فوائد العلاج والتعافي منه فعند اكتشاف
اورام الثدي في المرحله الاولى تصبح نسبه
شفائها اكثر من 95% ويمكن الكشف عن سرطان
الثدي من خلال نوعين من الكشف وهما الذاتي
والسرير الفحص الذاتي يتم اجرائه مره
شهريا من قبل الشخص نفسه ويكشف السرطان
بنسبه 25% اما سرطان عنق الرحم فهو
السرطان الرابع الاكثر شيوعا بين النساء
في العالم وقدرت حالته بنحو 600 الف حاله
في 2020
فيما تشير منظمه الصحه العالميه ان تشخيص
المبكر لسرطان عنق الرحم يمكن ان ينقذ
حياه اكثر من 300 الف امراه سنويا
تنضم الينا من عمان الاعلاميه رنده كراتش
رنده
صباح الخير اولا
اسمحي لي اني اقول
بدايه اقف لك احتراما شكرا جزيلا لانه
الانسان قد ينزوي عند التعرض لاول مصيبه
ولكن ان يكون نبراسا وقبسا يضيء للاخرين
طريق ربما هو موحش ويجهلون ولا يريدون
السير فيه فهذه شجاعه منك شكرا جزيلا
وخليني اعرف ربما شفنا الفيديو لكن في بين
طيات الفيديو
ما لم
يتم الحديث عنه شعور غير ما كنت فيه على
على الفيديو اللي ظهرت فيه تفضل
ادري سؤالي طويل والله راويه عادل جميع
المشاهدين صباح الخير لكم لا بالعكس
اشكركم واشكر العربيه لوجودي معكم اليوم
صدقا عادل يمكن كما تفضلت من لحظه اكتشاف
في الاورام لغايه هذا اليوم هي تجربه
مؤلمه ما زالت مؤلمه بكل تفاصيلها الالم
موجود
والحال لن يتغير لكن اللي بيتغير وهو
تقبل الموضوع وجدت نفسي كما تفضلت امام
مفترق طرق يا اما انطوي على نفسي واسكر
على الموضوع واعيش هذا الالم لوحدي او اني
اشارك الجميع
بهذه التجربه
ونشر الوعي والامل في هذا الشان
صورت الفيديو وصدقا حضرت الفيديو ولم
اتقبل رؤيه نفسي بهذا الوجع وهذا الالم
تركتم حكي انا ما راح انشر هذا الفيديو
شعور داخلي بقى كل يوم اصحى واحس انه لا
في مسؤوليه اكبر وهذا الفيديو يجب ان
ينتشر وصوتي لازم يطلع
لحد ما اخذت القرار انه خلص انا راح انشر
الفيديو
واكتشف انه الثامن من ايار هو اليوم
العالمي اللي سرطان المبايض
نشرت الفيديو هو وجود اليوم هو ليس بسبب
نشري لهذا الفيديو هو بسبب
متابعين كثر حول العالم قرروا ان يضموا
صوتهم لصوتي لنشر هذه الرساله رساله مهمه
جدا راويه وعادل كميه زي ما حكى عادل يعني
كلك شجاعه للحديث والخوض في هذا الموضوع
ومحاوله انك تفيدي غيرك من هذه التجربه
رغم المها الكبير رنده خلينا نركز على
موضوع يعني رسالتك انت من خلال هذا
الفيديو ومن خلال هذه التجربه اللي انت م
فيها اللي هي تجربه انه رساله الوعي الفحص
المبكر عنا مشكله يمكن في العالم العربي
بانه يعني فحص المبكر لسرطان عنق الرحم
سرطان المبايض ما بيصير اصلا هو المفروض
يكون فحص دوري بعد الزواج سنه الزواج
عماله بيتاخر عنا
يعني بحس انه ما في كثير وعي لضروره عمل
هذا الفحص حتى وان كانت الصبيه سنها صغير
صدقا راويه يمكن هذا الشيء اللي انا شعرته
ولمسته من خلال المتابعين ومن خلال مشاركه
التجارب الشخصيه اللي هم عم بيمروا فيها
ربما يمكن احنا بنعرف انه سرطان الثدي او
السرطان عمق الرحم بلشنا نسمع شوي عن
الوعي اكثر في في هذا الشان لكن بالتحديد
سرطان المبيض ما يعني في ناس بقولوا لي
احنا ما كنا عارفين انه الثامن من ايار له
يوم هذا النوع من السرطانات لغايه الان في
ناس عم بيبعثوا لي ليش شلتي رحم ليش شلت
الموبايل وكل هذا الموضوع فيمكن من خلالكم
اليوم ومن خلال
هذا الشيء صار موضوع وعي بالفحص المبكر
موضوع مهم جدا احنا اليوم رسالتنا اكبر
ليس فقط في الاردن لكن لنشرها في العالم
العربي والعالم اجمع
صدقا بس اسمحي لي راويه وعاد اوجه تحيه
لكل المتابعين لكل شخص انا وجودي اليوم
معكم هو بسبب ضم صوتهم لصوتي ونشر هذه
الرساله حول العالم
اليوم يمكن شو رسالتي او ما القادم
انا يعني اليوم بفكر بصوت عالي معكم ربما
بنشر وعي اكبر في هذا الموضوع يمكن
يكون النا جمعيه يكون لنا صوت مرتفع حول
العالم ما بعرف يعني يعني اليوم انا اقول
ربما هذا الجزء مهم بالنسبه للمراه ليس
فقط المطالبه بالحقوق الاجتماعيه ايضا
توعيه المراه هو حق كبير على النساء الوطن
العربي على الاعلاميات وغير الاعلاميات
شكرا جزيلا رنده امامك درب طويل اعلم ذلك
شكرا لوقوفك في وجه في وجه كل الاحباطات
اللي من الممكن كانت تدفع اي امراه الى
تقول ما لي علاقه بهذا العالم لانزوي
واعالج مصيبتي لوحدي شكرا جزيلا الرانده
شكرا لكم عادل شكرا راويه شكرا للجميع
تحياتنا لكم
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات